most people by now have done number two
number three and you notice some things
so let's get the answer together this is
2 and this is 3 ok what is the answer to
from ma I think it's like a couple of
fours 4 4 4 4 10 8 wait
yeah yeah right ok don't up and then
what was the answer for three yeah
two four wait seven ten okay now hold on
a second
does anyone notice what's fishy about
this something's weird isn't it look at
number two number three these are not
just random arbitrary questions they're
actually two sides of the same question
what's the difference between this
matrix and this matrix this matrix if
this desert did anyone notice it's the
same numbers although darn good some
people picked it up everyone I love it
when you had that boat over you like oh
well let's stay together as a class okay
yes all I've done is I've switched my
matrices okay now what that means is you
got say if we call this a and this B all
right a times B and B times a I'm not
equal they're not the same they're quite
different right so this is a bit weird
because we are used to multiplication
being what's the name for it when you
could swap the order that's fine
it starts with a say remember we've
talked about this a little bit it's
called commutated
its commutator now here's the big matrix
multiplication cross multiplication is
not commutative it's not coffee table
because if you change things the answer
you get up in is quite different now my
question to you is why why is it that I
can't just switch the order and get the
same answer yeah good okay so I love
that how an exhalation begins with it's
like the sushi okay good now let me try
and unpack that because it's exactly
right for this particular analogy when
we went through this and I gave you this
additional example right words match up
with columns and they match up in that
order right if I were to swap these do
these colors with these words as you can
see you get an entirely different answer
right so this here it implies order that
the order is meaningful right and if you
switch things around well of course
you'll get something different because
these rows and these columns aren't the
same
so cross multiplication is not
commutative what about the other kind of
multiplication dot dot burns
I've a commutator I'll make sure I'll
let you ever think about that answer now
therefore here's my next thing which I
get out of fact that it's not copy to
you do you notice that if you've moved
on to the next questions or even looked
at the original question that we started
off with this issue right
you can't just multiply any pair of
matrices it's not possible you can
multiply any number you like right no
matter what combination no matter what
pair of numbers you come up with you
always come up with a product right but
it's not this same with matrices I'll
give you a very quick example okay
let's change this question over here
let's suppose we started off without one
two three four matrix right and then try
to multiply it by I'm just thinking okay
let's do it like this okay instead of
this
now what happens what happens watch as
you start to go through the process
you're like okay add that shot this one
with this - and then I match up this
tune with this one and then you're like
oh it's got nothing to pair with what's
gone wrong uh this would mean right I've
got some I've got I'm selling some kind
of sushi but I don't have information
for right it doesn't it doesn't have
anything to match to however you might
know to this speak about this way what
if I reversed it what if I tried to
think about war what happens the other
way right if I go like this what happens
it's good it's gonna work isn't it but
there's something different about watch
we go this matches to this this matches
to this okay so you're going to get a
dot product of that and then you move
across two two zero two and four and
you'll get another dot product but now
because I've got three rows here right
I'm gonna end up with three rows here
okay so how do these dimensions work
look just by changing the order I got
something which doesn't have an answer
to something which does but we're
disturb engines come from where did
these dimensions come from where'd our
region will get its dimensions from I
started with one two three my time
remember what we multiplied it by it was
three by five what was the answer I got
up here what were its dimensions five by
one
Oh actually really one by five because
I'm naming rows and then columns when
it is justly divided by three but why
okay all right let me put these labels
on now and see if you can see what's
going on okay let's have a look at this
one
okay I'm going to go and this is a bit
tricky this is a bit counterintuitive
unfortunately but I'm gonna name Rose
first then Colin most columns rows
columns it matches to the order of
multiplication what's this what are the
debate over this rows three columns to
rows well this is just too much too
minute okay so the result was three by
two okay
have a look at this one right rows rows
one column three rows three columns five
answer 1 by 5 1 by 5 3 by 2 and now
perhaps you can see why this one breaks
watch what's wrong with this one
I tried to do two times two by two and
three by two but it broke why why did it
break what was wrong with this one that
the other two are fine with it's in the
middle I would say oh it doesn't match
what doesn't match these numbers don't
match these guys right whereas this 3 is
gonna match up with this 3 this twos
gonna match up with this 2 right and
this is exactly why we do it in this
order so you can see these bits are
going to collapse and you're just gonna
left be left with it so now you can't
predict for instance have a look at that
last one question 6 right one of the
dimensions you're getting you start with
at three by three and then you multiply
by are
Rose Collins Rose con 3x1 so then your
answer will be see these these inside
bits will cancel and you'll end up with
another three by one okay you see what's
going on all right now
Shh one last date and now that's not
talking about you just finish the
questions okay you remember I said you
remember I said that matrix
multiplication is not commutative now
you can't just switch the order there is
one exception to that rule one exception
and one exception only I'll shove it to
you or you might have a look at it
yourself if you've done question 4 if
you don't question for ya all right so
let's have a look at this together
because something all of you have you
can help me through it the answer now I
don't just want you to tell me answer I
want you to work it through with me but
as the people who've done it know it's
not that hard right so watch let's do
the first one okay
rows columns rows columns right so I'm
gonna go 1 times negative 1 and then 0
27 which is just 0 so you get negative 1
okay I'm gonna move across this row
stays the same but I look at the next
column 1 times 3 0 times 0 right move
over a column 1 times 8 0 times 2 hold
on it's getting bits us isn't it and by
this point you probably realized ok I'm
just going to get this so what's going
on you just got back exactly the same
answer I wonder if you remembered that
this matrix that we started with has a
name it's not just any matrix right what
matrix is this this is the identity
matrix why is it called the identity
matrix
it's our what you get at the end is
identical to what you started with okay
and this is the one exception matrix
multiplication is not commutative unless
you multiply by the identity matrix okay
because I can switch this around this is
going to be the same as this 7:02 times
the identity matrix it'll be the same
okay this is the one and only exception
by the way as if they are you're
probably not aware of this because they
don't talk about it very much this is
the identity matrix right there is also
the arm what we call the multiplicative
identity which is like well that's a
huge fancy name right do you know what
it is it's the number one why is one the
multiplicative identity because if you
take a number say it and you multiply it
by one you will get back the identical
thing right what do you think if this is
the identity matrix and this is the
multiplicative identity what do you
think the additive or the eye addition
identity is it's zero isn't it because
if you add zero you get back what's
identical okay so I hope that makes
sense of what this name is about